clearly a relatively minor attack in
terms of scale but how worried will
America be by an assault like this on
what effectively were the Moscow suburbs
yeah I mean this is exactly what the
United States would not want to see I
mean as the West has given weapons to uh
Kiev they've required assurances that
these would not be used in any direct
attack on Russia and Cave has given
those assurances and I'm sure they will
keep to it they will not use Western
weapons to attack Russia but if they're
using their own weapons to attack Russia
and these are not military targets I
mean if these drones were directed
towards a military Target they obviously
are shot down short so they're going to
land somewhere so you've got to take
responsibility for that so if Ukraine
was behind these attacks and I still say
that it's an if at the moment but if
they were then they're sailing very very
close to the wind they'll say well you
know if we did attack Russia we didn't
use Western weapons to do it that point
will be lost on the Russians the
Russians will simply make the point that
you're attacking our homeland we know
that you're doing that because you're
trying to destroy Russia and NATO and
the United States is behind you because
of now war with Russia it's Putin's
narrative it's Pluto Putin's Playbook
which is why
Ukraine will be very foolish if it
engaged in these attacks deliberately
even indirectly through some sort of
paramilitary group inside where that's
always plausible because some of the
drones that we're talking about are
commercially available uh you know
private groups do have them because
they're not all military these drones
can be used for Photography they can use
for filming they just carry something
they're just simple aircraft which can
carry about 20 kilos of something so
that's entirely plausible but if that's
the case kiva's got to actually make its
case it's got to it's got a torque noise
it's simply saying it's nothing to do
with us that's been okay until now
um because with the singing with the
Moscow they sort of said no it's not us
and then they winked you know nothing to
do with us big wink they mustn't do that
this time if it's not if they're not
behind this they've got to try to make
that clear if they are behind it then
they should say so and make their
reasons clear because if they're accused
of it and can't actually get away from
the accusation it plays to Putin's
narrative and it makes people in the
west very very nervous well with that in
mind could it affect if they are it
turns out they are behind it will
probably never know could it affect
future military assistance well it would
affect the political arguments that go
on in the west about future military
systems the assistance they've got is
there now but another wave of military
assistance will almost certainly have to
be given in the Autumn and that will be
a big issue because there's not that
much more stuff that can be easily
transferred military equipment can be
usually given to Ukraine and we're all
going to face another round of these
arguments we in the west come the Autumn
and if the political opposition to
aiding Ukraine has been has been
strengthened by this sort of thing then
that will be quite poor for Ukraine's
cause Okay Michael thank you very much
indeed